Off a busy street in Brooklyn, New York, sits a storefront called Monica's Hair Salon. A salon, our producer Priscilla Alabi, visited a few weeks ago. I've been going to hair salons like this since I was little. There are places where people come for their hair, but also for advice, gossip, celebrations. Oh, I love us. I just love us so much. A woman pops it. What you want? Not for an appointment.
在纽约布鲁克林一条繁华的街道旁，坐落着一家名为莫妮卡美发沙龙（Monica's Hair Salon）的店铺。我们的制作人普莉西拉·阿拉比（Priscilla Alabi）几周前曾拜访过这家沙龙。我从小就一直去这种美发沙龙。这里是人们来做头发的地方，但也交流建议、八卦和庆祝活动。哦，我太喜欢我们了。我真的太喜欢我们了。一个女人尖叫着爆发了。你想要什么？不是为了预约。
But to ask for a birthday hug. Well, this young lady has been taking care of me since I was like 12. This is Lorraine Samuel's salon. She's been here since 1996. Today, she's about to give a customer a classic salon treatment. One I've been thinking a lot about lately. What are you doing to your customers here right now? I'm giving her a relaxer.
而是来要一个生日抱抱。这位年轻女士从我大概 12 岁起就一直在照顾我。这是洛林·塞缪尔（Lorraine Samuel）的沙龙。她从 1996 年起就在这里了。今天，她正准备为一位顾客做一项经典的美发护理。这个护理我最近一直在琢磨。你现在在这里对你的顾客做什么？我正在给她做顺直烫（relaxer）。
I was nine. maybe 10 years old, the first time a chemical relaxer touched my virgin hair. That's the actual term for unprocessed hair. My natural kinky coils made hair grooming days very challenging, so my mom and I decided to relax my hair to make it more manageable. I was so excited for the possibility of long, flowy hair that a comb could easily pass through. So what does it look like the actual physical object itself? Hmm, kind of like cream cheese a little bit.
我九岁，也许十岁的时候，第一次有化学顺直剂接触到我从未处理过的头发。那是未经处理的头发的实际术语。我天生紧密卷曲的头发让头发护理的日子变得非常具有挑战性，所以我妈妈和我决定做顺直，让头发更容易打理。我当时非常兴奋，幻想着能拥有那种梳子可以轻易梳理的长而飘逸的头发。那么它实际的物理物体长什么样呢？嗯，有点像奶油芝士。
It comes to the tub, like usually a plastic tub. It doesn't smell like anything. This one. This one doesn't. But it probably burns this one way though, right? It does. Yeah. The first time I was preparing to get my hair relaxed, I was instructed very seriously.
它装在一个罐子里，通常是塑料罐。它没有任何气味。这个。这个没有。但这东西最后可能会灼伤头皮，对吧？确实会。是的。我第一次准备做头发顺直时，收到了非常严肃的指示。
Don't wash or scratch your scalp for at least one week before your appointment, because that would cause burns. In previous salon visits, I was a little bit of a little bit of your scalp for at least one week before your appointment, visits, I'd seen women yowl when the pain got unbearable. I didn't know it then, but I was being initiated into something much bigger than a hairstyle. And it burns towards the end if you leave it in too long. So you're just supposed to end it to the hair shaft and then keep applying it, the creamy crack.
预约前至少一周不要洗头或抓头皮，因为这会导致灼伤。在以往的沙龙访问中，我有一点……在预约前至少一周抓你的头皮，访问中，我曾看到女性在疼痛变得难以忍受时发出哀号。我当时并不知道，但我正在被引入一个远比发型大得多的仪式。如果你把顺直剂留在头上太久，最后会产生灼烧感。所以你只需要把它涂抹在发干上，然后继续涂抹，这种“奶油毒瘾”。
That's the relaxer's nickname, Creamy Crack. Because it's said that relaxing your hair, is addictive. Once you start, it's very hard to stop. If you stop, the hair breaks off where the new curly growth meets the already straightened dead hair. You see it? You see it getting straight? Oh yeah, there's no resistance in that hair anymore with a comb, in the hair in the back where you started. Wow. You see the tough one? Yeah. Today, somewhere between 85 and 95% of black women in the United States, have used a chemical relaxer at least once in their lifetime,
那是顺直剂的绰号，叫“奶油毒瘾”（Creamy Crack）。因为据说顺直头发会让人上瘾。一旦你开始，就很难停下来。如果你停下来，新长出的卷发与已经拉直的死发交汇处就会断裂。你看到了吗？你看到它变直了吗？哦，是的，梳子在头发中再也没有阻力了，在最开始的后脑勺头发里。哇。你看到那撮坚硬的了吗？是的。今天，美国有 85% 到 95% 的黑人女性一生中至少使用过一次化学顺直剂，
as I did starting at age nine for years. Fast forward to 2023 while scrolling through Instagram, a targeted ad stopped me cold. If you used chemical hair straightener and were later diagnosed with uterine fibroids, contact our office today. A law firm wants me to join in a class action lawsuit. I had just been diagnosed with fibroids, a condition that disproportionately affects black women.
就像我从九岁开始持续多年的那样。快进到 2023 年，当我在 Instagram 上刷动态时，一则定向广告让我瞬间僵住。如果你使用过化学美发顺直剂后来被诊断出患有子宫肌瘤，请立即联系我们的办公室。一家律师事务所想让我加入集体诉讼。我刚刚被诊断出患有肌瘤，这是一种不成比例地影响黑人女性的疾病。
New research linking chemical hair relaxer to uterine fibroids may help explain this disparity. There are many ads like this. Did you or a loved one develop cancer after using hair relaxing or hair straightening products? If so, you may be able to sue the hair product manufacturer for damages. Fibroids, uterine cancer, ovarian cancer, all implying that this thing so many black women use happening in so many salons across America and even the world could actually be making us sick. From 99% Invisible in BBC Studios, this is the history of the United States in 100 Objects. I'm Roman Mars.
将化学头发顺直剂与子宫肌瘤联系起来的新研究可能有助于解释这种差异。有很多这样的广告。你或你爱的人在使用美发顺直或定型产品后患上癌症了吗？如果是这样，你或许可以起诉美发产品制造商要求赔偿。肌瘤、子宫癌、卵巢癌，这一切都暗示着这么多黑人女性使用、发生在全美乃至全世界那么多沙龙里的东西，实际上可能正在让我们生病。来自 99% Invisible 和 BBC Studios，这就是 100 件物品中的美国历史。我是罗马·马尔斯（Roman Mars）。
Today, the chemical hair relaxer, a ubiquitous American product that built black wealth and opened economic doors. But it also taught generations. to see their hair as a problem to be solved. And now research is revealing a physical cost. This is the story of how those two truths came to exist at the same time. Producer Priscilla Ala B. has the story. When I saw the targeted ad soon after my fibro diagnosis, I wanted answers.
今天，化学头发顺直剂，这个创造了黑人财富并打开经济大门的美国无处不在的产品。但它也教导了几代人将自己的头发视为一个亟待解决的问题。现在，研究揭示了其中的生理代价。这就是这两种真理如何同时存在的故事。制作人普莉西拉·阿拉比（Priscilla Ala B.）为您讲述这个故事。当我被诊断出肌瘤后不久看到这则定向广告时，我想要答案。
How did we get here? Where so many black women were doing this to ourselves? My name is Lori L. Tharps. and I am a journalist and the co-author of Hair Story, untangling the roots of black hair in America. So I reached out to Lori Tharps, a journalist and hair historian who spent the last quarter century asking similar questions about hair.
我们是怎么走到这一步的？为什么这么多的黑人女性在对自己做这种事？我叫洛莉·L·萨普斯（Lori L. Tharps），我是一名记者，也是《美发史：解开美国黑人头发之根》（Hair Story: Untangling the Roots of Black Hair in America）一书的合著者。因此，我联系了洛莉·萨普斯，她是一位记者兼发型历史学家，在过去的四分之一世纪里一直在提出关于头发的类似问题。
So in your research, what surprised you most about the relationship black Americans have with their straightening their hair? I think the thing that was the most interesting and not in a good way was how early the quest for straightening our hair began as enslaved individuals, and the fact that that yearning for straight hair as a source of assimilation is still with us. But Lori says starting the story with enslavement is like starting at chapter two.
那么在你的研究中，美国黑人与他们拉直头发的关系中，什么最让你感到惊讶？我认为最有趣、而且不是好的一面，是我们对头发顺直的追求作为被奴役的个人开始得有多早，以及对作为同化之源的直发的渴望至今仍然伴随着我们。但洛莉说，从奴役开始讲述这个故事就像是从第二章开始。
You miss a lot of context. And when you skip chapter one, black people end up looking obsessed, even though. pathological about their hair. If you go chapters before arrival, then we know that black people have always been artistic and creative with hairstyling. There was a rich hair dressing tradition in Africa. That was a part of their culture. Hair styling was fundamental to showcasing and sharing your identity.
你漏掉了大量的背景。当你跳过第一章时，黑人最终看起来对他们的头发着迷，甚至到了病态的地步。如果你追溯到到达之前的几个章节，我们就会知道黑人对发型设计一直很有艺术感和创造力。非洲有着丰富的美发传统。那是他们文化的一部分。发型设计是展示和分享身份的基础。
You had a hairstyle that connected you to a tribe, to a family, to a people. It's an ancestral heritage. So when Africans were enslaved and brought to America, their hairdressing traditions transformed. What used to be a way to express yourself that connects you to your people and your identity suddenly became a strategy for survival. Black people were interested in straightening their hair very soon after being kidnapped and brought to the colonies because they were told. that their hair was inferior, that it was ugly, that it was more animalistic. We simply wanted to stop being treated like animals. And then hair straightening became a visual way to demonstrate our equality.
你拥有一个将你与部落、家庭、民族联系起来的发型。这是一种祖先的遗产。因此，当非洲人被奴役并带到美洲时，他们的美发传统发生了转变。过去那种表达自我、将你与族人和身份联系起来的方式，突然变成了一种生存策略。黑人对拉直头发产生兴趣是在被绑架并带到殖民地后不久，因为他们被告知他们的头发是低劣的、丑陋的、更加野蛮的。我们只是想停止被当作动物对待。然后，头发顺直成为展示我们平等的视觉方式。
So they innovated. They created new techniques and tools from what was available. They had to get creative because they didn't have the tools or materials that they had in Africa. So instead of something like palm oil that was very common in Africa to soften the hair, they would use butter. They turned cornmeal and kerosene into shampoo, baking grease and butter into conditioner. Butter knives became crude flat irons. They would wrap the hair in yarn to kind of pull the kinks out. Very inventive, very creative methods.
所以他们进行了创新。他们利用现有的东西创造了新的技术和工具。他们必须发挥创造力，因为他们没有在非洲时拥有的工具或材料。因此，他们没有使用非洲非常常见的棕榈油来软化头发，而是使用黄油。他们将玉米面和煤油变成洗发水，将培根油和黄油变成护发素。黄油刀成了粗糙的直发器。他们会用纱线包裹头发来把卷曲拉直。非常富有发明创造力的方法。
They were so inventive that they'd change. techniques became legendary. So sought after that they became the barbers and wig makers of choice for white people. White people paid for their hands, their skill, their artistry, and that access to wealth, that became a pathway. They were able to make enough money, so many of them, to buy themselves out of slavery. Many of the early black universities and other black institutions were at funded or founded by black barbers. For example, they funded Wilberforce University, one of the first HBCUs owned and operated entirely by African Americans, built in large part on the earnings from hairdressing. Now, interestingly, though, to be clear, the black barbers at this time were not barbering other black people's hair.
他们极具创造力，以至于他们的改变技术成为了传奇。大受欢迎，以至于他们成为了白人首选的理发师和假发匠。白人花钱购买他们的双手、技能、艺术才华，而通往财富的途径，则成为了一条康庄大道。他们赚到了足够的钱，其中许多人得以买回自由，脱离奴隶身份。早期许多黑人大学和其他黑人机构都是由黑人理发师资助或创立的。例如，他们资助了威尔伯福斯大学（Wilberforce University），这是第一所由非洲美国人完全拥有和运营的 HBCU 历史悠久的黑人大学，很大程度上建立在美发赚取的收入之上。然而，有趣的是，需要明确的是，当时的黑人理发师并不是在为其他黑人的头发理发。
They were barboring white people's hair, which is sadly ironic. because they couldn't do their own, I mean, maybe, you know, after hours, but they, you know, they couldn't have a barbershop where they did white clients and black clients because that would never fly. Black folks continue to innovate with their own hair, though. And by the early 1900s, that innovation would turn into full-fledged empires. Let's start with two women, Madam C.J. Walker and Annie Turnbull Malone, the first pioneers in black hair care as an industry.
他们是在为白人的头发理发，这可悲地具有讽刺意味，因为他们不能为自己理发，我的意思是，也许，你知道，在下班后，但他们，你知道，他们不能开一家既接待白人客户又接待黑人客户的理发店，因为那是行不通的。不过，黑人同胞继续对自己的头发进行创新。到了 20世纪初，这种创新将演变成成熟的商业帝国。让我们从两位女性开始，C.J.沃克夫人（Madam C.J.Walker）和安妮·特恩布尔·马龙（Annie Turnbull Malone），她们是黑人护发产业的第一批先驱。
They took the hodgepodge of hair straightening methods floating around and turned them into an actual system. Madam C.J. Walker and Annie Turnbone Malone became very wealthy by selling the idea of straight hair, but not with chemicals. They used hot combs and worked them through the hair with pomade to get a sleek straight look. But more importantly, they built an entire industry and economy around black hair care that, that didn't exist before. You have to remember that during slavery, black women were not given time to really pay attention to their hair
她们将流传的各种零散的头发顺直方法整理成了一个实际的系统。C.J.沃克夫人和安妮·特恩布·马龙通过销售直发的理念变得非常富有，但用的不是化学物质。她们使用热梳（hot combs），并在发油（pomade）的配合下将其穿过头发，以获得光滑直顺的外观。但更重要的是，她们围绕黑人护发建立了一个以前并不存在的完整产业和经济。你必须记住，在奴隶制时期，黑人女性没有时间真正关注自己的头发
in terms of like really taking care of it. Madam C.J. Walker and Andy Turnbone alone were both really good at creating a beauty culture around hair for black women. And so it was be like, we're gonna wash your hair, we're gonna massage your scalp, we're gonna straighten your hair, she popularized the system for straightening the hair. And in so doing, Madam C.J. Walker became the first self-made millionaire woman in America, black or white. But the issue with straightening your hair with a hot comb was that the
在真正照顾它们方面。C.J.沃克夫人和安迪·特恩布·马龙都非常擅长为黑人女性创造围绕头发的美丽文化。因此，就像是，我们要洗你的头发，我们要按摩你的头皮，我们要拉直你的头发，她普及了拉直头发的系统。通过这样做，C.J.沃克夫人成为了美国第一位白手起家的女性百万富翁，无论黑白。但用热梳拉直头发的问题在于
results were temporary, because once moisture hit the hair, sweat, humidity, rain, it went back to its natural state. But someone was about to find a permanent solution. and completely by accident. Garrett Augustus Morgan was a tailor in Cleveland, Ohio in the early 1900s. He was trying to create a substance that would prevent high-speed machines and needles from destroying material like wool and other animal fur. One day, he tried a particular concoction and he noticed the thick texture of the fur relaxed. It became straight.
效果是暂时的，因为一旦水分接触到头发，汗水、湿气、雨水，它就会恢复到自然状态。但有人即将找到一个永久的解决方案，而且完全是偶然的。加勒特·奥古斯都·莫尔根（Garrett Augustus Morgan）是 20世纪初俄亥俄州克利夫兰的一名裁缝。他试图创造一种物质，以防止高速机器和针具破坏羊毛和其他动物毛皮等材料。有一天，他尝试了一种特定的混合物，并注意到毛皮的浓稠质地变软了。它变直了。
Next, he tries a solution on his neighbor's dog, which is a little suss, but the dog's fur comes out straight. Morgan then tries a substance on his own hair next, and his hair also becomes straight. And it was like an accidental discovery. He accidentally discovered that if you mix Lai and some other things, we could straighten the hair. Lye, spelled L-Y-E, a sodium hydroxide, a caustic chemical that people already knew could straighten hair. But it was too dangerous, too. corrosive to use safely. What Morgan found was a formula that made it possible to use
接下来，他在邻居的狗身上尝试了一种溶液，这有点可疑，但狗的毛发变直了。莫尔根接着在自己的头发上尝试了这种物质，他的头发也变直了。这就好像是一个偶然的发现。他偶然发现，如果你把碱液（Lye）和其他一些东西混合在一起，我们就可以把头发拉直。碱液，拼写为 L-Y-E，一种氢氧化钠，一种人们已经知道可以拉直头发的苛性化学品。但它太危险了，腐蚀性太强，无法安全使用。莫尔根发现的是一个使之成为可能的配方
lie on human hair more safely, but it was still risky. And it was men, not women, who first were willing to gamble with the new chemical straightener, particularly jazz musicians. They wanted that sleek, processed look. They called it the conk. And one of the most iconic lores about this conk look is one featuring the equally iconic Malcolm X, when he was a teenager who had just moved to the big city of Boston. And the story that he shares about how important it was for him to look cool, for him, you know, he had his zoot suit. He wanted to be, you know, somebody in the streets of Boston. And he had the look, but he said that his nappy red hair, I'm paraphrasing, but his nappy red hair gave him away as being country, not being citified in, you.
更安全地在人类头发上使用碱液，但它仍然是有风险的。而且是男性，而不是女性，首先愿意用这种新的化学顺直剂冒险，尤其是爵士乐手。他们想要那种光滑、经过处理的外观。他们称之为“孔克头”（conk）。关于这种孔克头外观最具标志性的传说之一，就是关于同样标志性的马尔科姆·X（Malcolm X）的，当时他还是个刚搬到波士顿大城市的少年。他分享的故事是关于保持帅气对他有多么重要，对他而言，你知道，他有他的阔腿西装（zoot suit）。他想成为波士顿街头的一个人物。他拥有了那种外表，但他却说他那蓬乱的红头发——我是在意译——但他那蓬乱的红头发暴露了他来自乡下，不是城里人，你知道。
having that slicked hair showed that you were truly from the city. And so they told him it was going to burn, but he didn't care. It was worth it for him. You watch the Malcolm X biopic movie with Denzel Washington, that scene where he throws his head in the toilet.
拥有那种梳理得光亮的头发表明你真正来自城市。所以他们告诉他会烧伤，但他不在乎。对他来说这是值得的。你看丹泽尔·华盛顿（Denzel Washington）主演的马尔科姆·X传记电影，就是他把头扎进马桶的那场戏。
In Spike Lee's film about Malcolm X, there's a scene where the water went out just as Malcolm's hair is burning from Lye. He has nowhere to rinse. So he dunks his head into a toilet bowl just as the police burst into the place. Although that scene was a creative liberty Spike Lee took, the scene became a symbol of the lengths that many black people would go to assimilate.
在斯派克·李（Spike Lee）关于马尔科姆·X的电影中，有一个场景，就在马尔科姆的头发被碱液灼烧时，水停了。他无处冲洗。因此，就在警察闯入这个地方的那一刻，他把头浸入了一个马桶盆里。尽管那个场景是斯派克·李采取的艺术自由，但这个场景成为了许多黑人为同化而不惜付出一切代价的象征。
Looking at it now, that scene represents an opportunity, a gap in the market that was waiting to be filled, because someone's going to figure out a way to not only make using life safer, but to make it sellable and accessible. His name is George Johnson, and his innovation will make him one of the most powerful black entrepreneurs America has ever been, ever seen. I consider him like the Madam C.J. Walker of his era in the black hair care industry because he literally made a fortune from his hair care products. He was the first person to make
现在回想起来，那个场景代表了一个机会，一个等待被填补的市场空白，因为有人会想出一种方法，不仅让使用碱液更安全，而且使其具有可销售性和可及性。他的名字叫乔治·约翰逊（George Johnson），他的创新将使他成为美国有史以来、从未见过的最强大的黑人企业家之一。我认为他就像黑人护发行业他那个时代的 C.J.沃克夫人，因为他确实通过他的护发产品发了财。他是第一个制造
a lot of money, packaging and, you know, creating a whole business around the relaxer. But his first relaxer was actually for men. A barber who was doing these homemade conks came to George Johnson, who was a chemist and said, hey, can you make some things that I can do quickly and easily? And that's how he came up with his ultra-wave product, which was a relaxer for men. He then followed that up with one for women called the ultrashine relaxer. And I guarantee probably every black women of a certain age, kind of Gen X and above, have heard of or had an ultrashine relaxer on their head at some point or their mother had or their sister has. George Johnson's products owned the market.
通过包装并围绕顺直剂创造整个商业帝国而赚取巨额财富的人。但他的第一款顺直剂实际上是为男性准备的。一位一直在做这种自制孔克头的理发师找到了乔治·约翰逊，他是一名化学家，并说，嘿，你能做一些我可以快速轻松完成的东西吗？这就是他想出他的超波浪（ultra-wave）产品的方式，这是一种针对男性的顺直剂。随后，他又推出了针对女性的产品，名为超光泽顺直剂（ultrashine relaxer）。我敢保证，一定年龄的每一个黑人女性，X 世代及以上左右的人，都听说过或在某个时候在头上用过超光泽顺直剂，或者她们的母亲用过，或者她们的姐妹用过。乔治·约翰逊的产品统治了市场。
Unlike the straightening combs with temporary results or the dangerous lie concoctions people were mixing up at home, ultrachine was long-lasting and safer, and you could buy it at any drugstore. You didn't have to go to the salon to get it done, although you could go to the salon. It just revolutionized and in some ways made hair care for black people way more efficient and affordable
与效果短暂的直发梳或人们在家里混合的危险碱液混合物不同，超光泽产品持久且更安全，你可以在任何药店买到。你不必去沙龙完成它，尽管你可以去沙龙。它彻底革新了，并在某些方面使黑人头发护理更加高效和实惠
by being able to get that relaxer at your local drugstore and do your hair for yourself. You could straighten your hair at home. Nobody had to know. That privacy was everything. There has to be mentioned that there was an aspect of shame, if I'm being honest, about the fact that we had to use chemicals to straighten our hair. And by being able to buy your relaxer at the drugstore and do it at home, nobody had to see you going out or going to the salon or anything like that to get it done. George Johnson became a multimillionaire and took the profits from his company and reinvested them back into the black community. Soul Train, Essence Magazine, platforms where black culture was presented as vibrant, sophisticated, and beautiful, just as it was. He went even further. Independence Bank in Chicago, the largest black-owned bank in the country, giving loans to people
通过能够在当地药店买到那种顺直剂并自己做头发。你可以自己在家拉直头发。没有人必须知道。这种隐私是一切。如果老实说，不得不使用化学物质来拉直头发这一事实，必须提一下，其中存在一种羞耻感。通过能够在药店买到顺直剂并在家里做，没有人必须看到你出门或去沙龙或做类似的事情来完成它。乔治·约翰逊成为了一名千万富翁，并将他公司的利润重新投资于黑人社区。《灵魂列车》（Soul Train）、《精华》杂志（Essence Magazine），这些平台将黑人文化呈现为充满活力、精致和美丽，正如它本来那样。他走得更远。芝加哥独立银行（Independence Bank），全国最大的黑人拥有银行，向人们发放贷款
redlined by white banks, to homeowners, to entrepreneurs. He funded civil rights leaders like Dr. Martin Luther King Jr. and Reverend Jesse Jackson. He employed hundreds of black and brown workers who couldn't get hired anywhere else because of racial discrimination in corporate America. They got profit share in the company. full health care, an on-site nurse, college tuition paid in full, paid maternity and sick leave, four-day weekends for every holiday, unheard of in corporate America back then. By 1964, the Johnson Products Company became the first black-owned company traded on the American Stock Exchange.
被白人银行划为红线的人、房主、企业家。他资助了马丁·路德·金（Martin Luther King Jr.）博士和杰西·杰克逊（Jesse Jackson）牧师等民权领袖。他雇用了数百名黑人和棕色人种工人，由于美国企业界的种族歧视，他们其他地方根本无法被录用。他们获得了公司的利润分享。全面的医疗保健、现场护士、全额支付的大学学费、带薪产假和病假、每个假期的四天周末，这在当时的美国企业界是闻所未闻的。到 1964 年，约翰逊产品公司（Johnson Products Company）成为第一家在美国证券交易所上市的黑人拥有公司。
But soon, the government started selectively regulating Johnson's products. So it was very interesting in 1975 when the Federal Trade Commission said that Johnson Products had to issue a warning on the outside of the boxes of their relaxers, that these products were made with lie, indicating that they could be harmful, right? But the FTC didn't require that all companies that sell hair relaxers have a warning label. In fact, the beauty company Revlon had launched their own relaxer that could. contain lie, but they weren't immediately required to add a warning label. And to this day, as far as I know, I could be wrong, but we have never been able to find my co-author and I, we've never been able to find a reason why Revlon didn't have to put the warning on, even though they also had lie in their products.
但不久之后，政府开始选择性地监管约翰逊的产品。因此，在 1975 年，联邦贸易委员会（Federal Trade Commission）表示，约翰逊产品公司必须在其顺直剂包装盒外部发布警告，表明这些产品是用碱液制成的，表明它们可能是有害的，这非常有趣，对吧？但联邦贸易委员会并未要求所有销售头发顺直剂的公司都必须带有警告标签。事实上，美妆公司露华浓（Revlon）推出了他们自己的顺直剂，可能含有碱液，但他们并未被立即要求添加警告标签。直到今天，据我所知，我可能是错的，但我和我的合著者从来没有能够找到，我们从来没有能够找到为什么露华浓不必加上警告的原因，尽管他们的产品中也含有碱液。
It took almost two years for the FTC to make Revlon add the warning. Two years where Revlon could market their products as if their lie, L-Y-E, was safer than Johnson's. In those two years, Revlon got a foothold. By the time Revlon was forced to add the warning, the damage was done. Ultra Sheen's market dominance was lost for good. Why were they targeted, but their competition, their white-owned competition was not. It's a mystery or a conspiracy, but it is widely understood that black-owned hair companies, again, since black people were in the hair business, which we know is pretty much since they were brought to this country, have always reinvested their money into the black community. Whether that was in scholarships, whether that was in community centers, Madam C.J. Walker built a theater in Indiana, like, for black people because they were not allowed in white people's theaters, you know?
联邦贸易委员会花了将近两年时间才让露华浓加上了警告。在这两年里，露华浓可以将其产品推销得好像他们的碱液（L-Y-E）比约翰逊的更安全。在那两年里，露华浓站稳了脚跟。等到露华浓被迫加上警告时，损害已经造成了。超光泽产品的市场主导地位一去不复返了。为什么他们成为目标，而他们的竞争对手、白人拥有的竞争对手却没有？这是一个谜，或者是一个阴谋，但人们普遍理解，黑人拥有的美发公司，再次强调，既然黑人从事美发行业，我们知道这几乎可以追溯到他们被带到这个国家的时候，他们总是把钱重新投资到黑人社区。无论是奖学金，还是社区中心，C.J.沃克夫人在印第安纳州建立了一个剧院，就像是，为黑人建造的，因为他们不允许进入白人的剧院，你知道吗？
So when black-owned hair companies either get taken over or the competition from white companies feels biased in some way, black people get really angry about that because they know that the black hair care companies have always kind of, again, help the black community. It's also striking that this is one of the first ways that a black person becomes a millionaire. in America. It's a product that makes black hair look less like itself. Embedded in this product is such a strong tension between, like, you know, self-empowerment and then assimilation.
因此，当黑人拥有的美发公司要么被接管，要么来自白人公司的竞争在某种程度上让人感觉不公平，黑人对此感到非常愤怒，因为他们知道黑人美发护理公司总是某种程度上，再次强调，帮助了黑人社区。同样惊人的是，这是黑人成为美国百万富翁最早的途径之一。这是一个让黑人头发看起来不那么像它自己的产品。这个产品中嵌入了如此强烈的张力，介于，你知道，自我赋权和同化之间。
And it's also the source of wealth and self-improvement for the black community. It feels kind of messed up. Like, what's that about? It does feel messed up. It feels very messed up. And I think it just, speaks to the complexity of being black in America. I don't have an answer for you.
这也是黑人社区财富和自我提升的源泉。感觉有点糟糕。这到底是怎么回事？确实感觉很糟糕。感觉非常糟糕。我认为这只是说明了身在美国黑人的复杂性。我没有答案给你。
I just can co-sign on the fact that this is incredibly complicated, but it signifies something about the pains and the lengths that we as black people will go to to assimilate. But there was a cost no one told us about. The costs were only now beginning to understand. That's after the break. At the same time that George Johnson is having the struggles with the FTC in the 70s, the Black Power Movement is taking off. And hair, of course, becomes central to the movement. During the Black Power Movement, Black people decided that straightening their hair hadn't solved any problems.
我只能赞同这样一个事实：这极其复杂，但它表明了我们作为黑人为了同化而要经历的痛苦和长度。但有一个没有人告诉我们的代价。这些代价我们现在才刚刚开始理解。休息之后继续。就在乔治·约翰逊在 70 年代与联邦贸易委员会作斗争的同时，黑人权力运动（Black Power Movement）正在腾飞。当然，头发也成为了运动的核心。在黑人权力运动期间，黑人决定拉直头发并没有解决任何问题。
You know, they've been straightening their hair, starting with Madam C.J. Walker, you know, with straightening combs and now relaxers, whatever it takes in order to play the game. And it hasn't worked. And so the idea with the Afro didn't start with the Afro. It started with something simpler and more radical. I'm not going to straighten my hair anymore. I'm going to use my hair as a form of protest. You will see the difference. You will see that I am a Negro, that I am different.
你知道，他们一直在拉直头发，从 C.J.沃克夫人开始，你知道，用直发梳，现在是顺直剂，为了玩这个游戏，付出一切代价。但这并没有奏效。所以非裔爆炸头（Afro）的理念并不是从非裔爆炸头开始的。它始于更简单、更激进的东西。我再也不会拉直我的头发了。我要把我的头发作为一种抗议的形式。你会看到区别。你会看到我是一个黑人，我是与众不同的。
I'm done making myself small. And what does black hair do? It expands. It grows up. It does not make you small. It makes you a little taller, you know? if you let it out, it will make you taller. It was a way to say, I'm angry, I'm fed up,
我不再让自己变得渺小。黑人头发会做什么？它在膨胀。它向上生长。它不会让你变小。它让你高了一点，你知道吗？如果你把它放下来，它会让你更高。这是一种表达方式，我在生气，我受够了，
and I'm not going to make myself small to make white people comfortable anymore. During the Black Power Movement, the politics flipped so hard that there are stories of black people who had naturally straight hair, getting perps to add curls. Not every black person has hair
我再也不会为了让白人感到舒适而让自己变得渺小了。在黑人权力运动期间，政治立场发生了如此剧烈的翻转，以至于有这样的故事：天生直发的黑人去做烫发以增加卷度。并不是每个黑人的头发都
that will look like an Angela Davis Afro. some people had to go get a perm to make their hair more curly. The idea was we want this look. I don't even have to say anything. I don't have to lift my fist in the air. I don't have to wear all black. If you see me with that hairstyle, then you understand that I'm part of the movement.
看起来像安吉拉·戴维斯（Angela Davis）的爆炸头。有些人不得不去烫发来让他们的头发更卷曲。这个想法是我们想要这种外观。我甚至不需要说什么。我不需要把拳头举在空中。我不需要穿全黑的衣服。如果你看到我留着那个发型，那么你就明白我是这场运动的一部分。
I'm ready to fight for my rights. Black hair was never just hair. It always makes a statement whether or not the wearer means anything by it. In his heyday, the Afro was radical. It was political. It was a statement of defiance. Then the beauty industry capitalized on the Afro. They made it profitable, selling wigs, marketing it as beautiful and empowering. And it was. But in making it profitable, they defanged it. It became just another fashion trend. By the 1980s, Straight was back. But there were also policies driving that return. For example, in 1981, a black woman named Renee Rogers worked as a
我已经准备好为我的权利而战。黑人头发从来不仅仅是头发。无论佩戴者是否有意，它总是能表达一种态度。在它的全盛时期，爆炸头是激进的。它是政治性的。它是一种反抗的宣言。然后美容行业利用了爆炸头。他们使之盈利，出售假发，将其作为美丽和赋权的象征进行营销。确实如此。但在使其盈利的过程中，他们磨去了它的锋芒。它成了又一个流行趋势。到了 20世纪 80 年代，直发又回来了。但也有政策推动了这种回归。例如，1981 年，一位名叫蕾妮·罗杰斯（Renee Rogers）的黑人女性担任
ticketing agent for American Airlines. She wore cornrows to work. The airline told her she couldn't. Rogers sued. She argued discrimination, but the judge ruled against her. He basically said hairstyles aren't a protected class. The airline said it wasn't about race. No one could have cornrows. But who was really wearing cornrows? The takeaway for black workers was, if you wanted to keep your job, you had to do your hair the way the company wanted. It was similar in the military. Actually, the military's policy was explicit. Black women could straighten their hair, but every hairstyle other than the afro involving natural textures like braids, twists, locks, those were all legally banable. So black folks kept on keeping on. If you had to straighten your hair,
美国航空公司（American Airlines）的票务代理。她梳着玉米垄头（cornrows）去上班。航空公司告诉她不行。罗杰斯起诉了。她辩称存在歧视，但法官作出了对她不利的裁决。他基本上说发型不是受保护的类别。航空公司表示这与种族无关。任何人都不准梳玉米垄头。但真正梳玉米垄头的是谁呢？给黑人工人的教训是，如果你想保住工作，你必须按照公司想要的方式做头发。军队里也是如此。事实上，军队的政策非常明确。黑人女性可以拉直头发，但除了解放黑人爆炸头之外的每一种涉及自然质地的发型，如辫子、扭辫、锁发，这些都是法律上应予禁令的。所以黑人同胞继续坚持下去。如果你必须拉直头发，
hair to work, you might as well make it fierce. In the 80s, that was the peak of black beauty and style. If I wanted to make a montage of the peak of straight hair in black America from the 80s to the 90s, what moments would you include? Okay, I would definitely get some shots from some of the hair shows that were really big in the 80s and 90s. Hair shows. These large-scale hairstyling competitions where the goal was to be as expressive and gravity-defying as possible. Stylists were sculpting bird cages out of hair with live birds, propellers, waterfalls, rotating carousels, all styles that required relaxing the hair. And if you want to understand the peak of that era, look nowhere else than at the iconic singer, Miss Patty LaBelle.
为了工作而去拉直头发，你最好把它弄得凶猛一点。在 80 年代，那是黑人美感和风格的巅峰。如果我想把 80 年代到 90 年代美国黑人直发的巅峰剪辑成一个蒙太奇，你会包括哪些时刻？好的，我绝对会加入一些 80 年代和 90 年代非常盛大的美发秀的镜头。美发秀。这些大规模的发型设计比赛，其目标是尽可能具有表现力和反重力。发型师们用活鸟、螺旋桨、瀑布、旋转旋转木马用头发雕刻出鸟笼，所有这些风格都需要拉直头发。如果你想了解那个时代的高峰，看看标志性的歌手帕蒂·拉贝尔（Miss Patty LaBelle）就知道了。
Every single Patty LaBelle hairstyle because Patty LaBelle really knew how to wear the wings. We did everything to my hair. I became the girl with the hair. Here she is in a recent interview with CBS Morning talking about a hairstyle she called The Bucket. We could put fruit in it or a chicken or whatever we wanted to eat in that bucket.
帕蒂·拉贝尔的每一个发型，因为帕蒂·拉贝尔真的很懂得如何佩戴翅膀。我们在我的头发上做了所有事情。我成了顶着头发的女孩。这是她在最近接受 CBS 早间新闻（CBS Morning）采访时谈到她称之为“水桶”（The Bucket）的发型。我们可以在里面放水果或鸡肉，或者任何我们想在这个水桶里吃的东西。
You stop it. You would put fruit in the hair. In her, because it was held together with awkwardness and it was real firm. And so I could put food in there. And the band one day just took an apple. It was a little apple and some grapes. From the bucket, I love it.
你别说了。你会在头发里放水果。在她那里，因为它是用尴尬感固定在一起的，而且非常坚固。所以我可以在里面放食物。乐队有一天拿了一个苹果。那是一个小苹果和一些葡萄。从水桶里，我太喜欢了。
Hair so sculpted that you could literally serve dinner from it. By the 90s, the straight hair culture had reached its absolute peak. Almost every singer, every, you know, video had black women with straight hair, whether they wear wigs. The straight look, just pick Naomi Canaan. or Tyra Banks at any given moment throughout the 90s. Wasteland, silky, bone straight. Every celebrity had it. Razor-cut textured pixie like Hallie berries
雕刻得如此精致的头发，你简直可以从中端出晚饭。到了 90 年代，直发文化达到了绝对的顶峰。几乎每一个歌手，每一个，你知道，视频里都有留着直发黑人女性，无论她们是否戴着假发。直发造型，只要挑选 90 年代任何特定时刻的娜奥米·坎贝尔（Naomi Campbell）或泰拉·班克斯（Tyra Banks）。荒凉、丝滑、如骨头般笔直。每个名人都拥有它。像哈莉·贝瑞（Halle Berry）那样剃刀剪质感的精灵短发，
or sleek, close-cropped pixie like Tony Braxton's. But by the mid to late 2000s, the tide was turning. The obsession with straight hair was starting to slow down. A green beauty movement was taking off. People were eating organic and thinking carefully about what they put in their body. So why weren't they asking the same questions about what they were putting on their bodies? Why were they slathering caustic chemicals on their hair and scalp every six to eight weeks? So people started embracing more natural styles.
或者像托妮·布莱斯顿（Tony Braxton）那样光滑、剪短的精灵短发。但到了 2000 年代中期到末期，风向开始转变。对直发的痴迷开始放缓。绿色美容运动正在腾飞。人们开始吃有机食品，并仔细思考他们吃进身体里的东西。那么，为什么他们不问同样的问题：他们往身体上涂抹了什么？为什么他们每隔六到八周就要在头发和头皮上涂抹腐蚀性化学品？因此，人们开始接受更多的自然发型。
I remember as a teenager just seeing all these black women like with natural hair and just being like, wait, what happened? Like we all just decided that we were not straightened our hair anymore. Yes, absolutely. So it's like, I don't need to. to buy a relaxer anymore because one of the main reasons that black women cited using relaxers was simply because it made their hair easier to manage. Well, now with the natural hair movement and the accompanying products, suddenly black hair wasn't so unmanageable.
我记得作为一名青少年，看到所有这些留着自然发型的黑人女性，只是觉得，等等，发生了什么？就像我们都决定不再拉直头发了一样。是的，绝对是这样。所以就像，我不需要了。不再购买顺直剂，因为黑人女性列出的使用顺直剂的主要原因之一很简单，因为它使头发更容易打理。好吧，现在有了自然发型运动和随之而来的产品，突然间黑人头发不再那么难以打理了。
The beauty industry felt it almost immediately. The numbers don't lie. From 2008 to 2013, relaxer sales plummeted 26%. At the same time, sales of natural hairstyling products like curl creams, moisturizers, and setting motions skyrocketed. And in real life, Lorraine Samuel saw the shift at her salon too. In the 90s, how often would you say you were
美容行业几乎立刻感受到了这一点。数字不会说谎。从 2008 年到 2013 年，顺直剂销量暴跌 26%。与此同时，卷发霜、保湿霜和定型露等自然发型产品的销量飙升。在现实生活中，洛林·塞缪尔也在她的沙龙里看到了这种转变。在 90 年代，你会说你多久做一次
using relaxers on people? Oh, maybe five times a day. Versus five times a week, which is now in 2026. If you were doing like 30, a week? Definitely. So now you're doing less. Now I'm doing about five a week. Oh, my God.
在人们头上使用顺直剂？哦，大概一天五次吧。相比之下，现在是 2026 年，一周五次。如果你像一周做 30 次？绝对是。所以现在你做的变少了。现在我一周大约做五次。哦，天哪。
So we don't spend as much in product. But in general, a feeling was growing. That this relaxer treatment can't be good for us. Then a few years ago, the science caught up to the fear. In 2002, a massive study would confirm what women had been sensing all along. I was really intrigued because that was the first. first time, there had been an association and a really good study linking hair relaxer products, black women, and two kinds of cancers, endometrial cancer and uterine cancer.
所以我们在产品上花钱不多了。但总的来说，一种感觉在增长。这种顺直剂护理对我们绝对没有好处。然后几年前，科学赶上了恐惧。2002 年，一项大规模的研究证实了女性一直以来的直觉。我真的很感兴趣，因为那是第一次。那是第一次，出现了一种关联，一项非常好的研究，将头发顺直剂产品、黑人女性和两种癌症（子宫内膜癌和子宫癌）联系起来。
That's Linda Villarosa, a contributing writer at the New York Times Magazine, where she covers health and social justice. I hadn't seen such good research about it before, but when this research came out, I said, oh, there's been a lot of smaller studies, but this big study means that maybe it's time to do an article. She published an article in 2024, discussing what scientists found from the NIH study. The conclusions from the research are alarming. It had followed 34,000 women and found that those who frequently used chemical hair straightening products and the majority of whom were black women were two and a half times more likely
那是琳达·维拉罗萨（Linda Villarosa），《纽约时报杂志》（New York Times Magazine）的特约撰稿人，她在那里负责健康和社会公正报道。我以前没见过这么好的研究，但当这项研究出来时，我说，哦，以前有很多小型研究，但这项大型研究意味着也许是时候写篇文章了。她在 2024 年发表了一篇文章，讨论了科学家从美国国立卫生研究院（NIH）的研究中发现了什么。研究结论令人震惊。它追踪了 34,000 名女性，发现那些经常使用化学美发顺直产品的人，其中绝大多数是黑人女性，可能性高出两倍半
to develop uterine cancer than those who did not. use them. Two and a half times more likely to develop uterine cancer. The 22 research makes an association with using relaxer products and ovarian, uterine, and endometrial cancer. So it's an association. It doesn't mean that if you used it, you will get cancer. It also doesn't mean you're going to die of it. Other research linked these products with fibroid tumors, and that is really important that we know because black women are much more likely than other women to get fibroid tumors. The study found correlation, not causation, a strong correlation between relaxer use and reproductive cancers. But for hair historian Lori Tharps, the distinction between correlation and causation misses the point. she doesn't think we should be cautious about it at all.
患子宫癌的几率是不使用者的两倍半。患子宫癌的几率高出两倍半。2022 年的研究将使用顺直产品与卵巢癌、子宫癌和子宫内膜癌联系起来。所以这是一种关联。这并不意味着如果你使用过它，你就会得癌症。这也不意味着你会因此死亡。其他研究将这些产品与纤维瘤联系起来，了解这一点真的很重要，因为黑人女性比其他女性更有可能患上纤维瘤。这项研究发现的是相关性，而不是因果关系，是顺直剂使用与生殖系统癌症之间的强相关性。但对发型历史学家洛莉·萨普斯来说，相关性和因果关系之间的区别抓错了重点。她认为我们根本不应该对此保持谨慎。
She thinks we should be waving a red flag, a big one, telling black women this product could cause cancer. And that's enough. There should be big warnings on the boxes, on the labels. Salons themselves should have warnings when a person wants to come in and do a treatment, a relaxer. They should be warned. This could give you, could give you fibroids or cancer.
她认为我们应该挥舞红旗，一面大红旗，告诉黑人女性这款产品可能会致癌。这就够了。包装盒上、标签上应该有巨大的警告。当有人想进来做护理、顺直时，沙龙本身应该有警告。他们应该得到警告。这可能会给你，可能会给你带来肌瘤或癌症。
sure you want it. If they're adequately warned and they still want to, you know, by all means, go for it. Cigarettes give you cancer and people still smoke, but a lot less do now than they did before because they understand the risks involved. But I do not believe by any stretch of imagination has this information been effectively disseminated. I think instead of calling it creamy crack, we should call it creamy cancer. That may be a start, but a loud warning won't change the social reality that makes black people reach for hair locksers in the first place. What it says about America is that if black people do their best to assimilate to white culture, there are riches to be made. If you can box assimilation, if you can put assimilation in a box
你确定要吗？如果他们得到了充分的警告，并且仍然想要，你知道，无论如何，去吧。香烟会导致癌症，人们仍然抽烟，但现在抽烟的人比以前少得多了，因为他们了解所涉及的风险。但我绝不相信这些信息得到了有效的传播。我认为我们不应该叫它“奶油毒瘾”，而应该叫它“奶油癌症”。这可能是一个开始，但大声的警告不会改变促使黑人首先寻找头发顺直剂的社会现实。它对美国的意义在于，如果黑人尽最大努力同化于白人文化，就有财富可图。如果你能把同化打包，如果你能把同化装进盒子里
and sell it on the stores of drugstores in America, that is the path to great wealth. but it comes at a price. And that price continues to be paid. We started this story with nine-year-old me wanting hair a comb could easily pass through. But to paraphrase Malcolm X in his 1962 speech in Los Angeles, who taught me to hate the texture of my hair? Who taught me that my natural hair wasn't beautiful, that I needed to change it to be acceptable?
并在美国的药店里出售，那是通往巨额财富的道路。但这是有代价的。而且这个代价仍在继续支付。我们从九岁的我开始这个故事，当时的我想要一头梳子可以轻易梳理的头发。但借用马尔科姆·X在 1962 年洛杉矶演讲中的话，是谁教我讨厌我的头发质地的？是谁教导我，我的自然头发并不美丽，我需要改变它才能被接受？
White supremacy is still real. racism is still real. People are still losing their jobs with natural hair styles. So even if this is dangerous, we still live in a world where straight hair is considered superior to natural kinky curly hair. So, you know, we're operating with this idea that something is dangerous, but white supremacy is dangerous. Lori L. Tharp's is the co-author of Hair Story, Untangling the Roots of Black Hair and America. A history of the United States and 100 Objects is a production of 99% Invisible and BBC studios. It's hosted and curated by me, Roman Mars. This episode was reported and produced by Priscilla
白人至上主义仍然是真实的。种族主义仍然是真实的。人们仍然因为自然发型而失去工作。所以即使这是危险的，我们仍然生活在一个直发被认为优于自然卷曲头发的世界里。所以，你知道，我们的运作理念是某事是危险的，但白人至上主义是危险的。洛莉·L·萨普斯是《美发史：解开美国黑人头发之根》的合著者。100 件物品中的美国历史是 99% Invisible 和 BBC Studios 的制作。由我罗马·马尔斯主持和策划。本集由普莉西拉报道和制作
Alibi. Our other producers are Ellie Lightfoot and Brenna Daldorf. Our associate producer is Isaac Fisher. This series was edited by Annie Brown and Courtney Harrell. Mixing by Iver Manly. Fact-checking by Amy Bracken. Our theme song is by Swan Real. From 99% Invisible, our executive producer is Kathy 2. From BBC Studios, our executive producers are Annie Brown and Courtney Harrell. Our production coordinator is Shan Palais, and the production manager is Mabel Finnegan Wright, artwork by Stefan Lawrence. 99% Invisible is part of the Serious XM podcast family,
阿拉比。我们的其他制作人是埃利·莱特富特（Ellie Lightfoot）和布伦娜·达尔多夫（Brenna Daldorf）。我们的副制作人是艾萨克·费舍尔（Isaac Fisher）。本系列由安妮·布朗（Annie Brown）和考特尼·哈雷尔（Courtney Harrell）编辑。伊弗·曼利（Iver Manly）混音。艾米·布拉肯（Amy Bracken）核实事实。我们的主题曲由斯旺·里尔（Swan Real）创作。来自 99% Invisible，我们的执行制作人是凯西·2（Kathy 2）。来自 BBC Studios，我们的执行制作人是安妮·布朗和考特尼·哈雷尔。我们的制作协调员是珊·帕莱（Shan Palais），制作经理是梅贝尔·芬尼根·赖特（Mabel Finnegan Wright），插图由斯特凡·劳伦斯（Stefan Lawrence）创作。99% Invisible 是 Serious XM 播客家族的一部分，
headquartered in Beautiful, Uptown, Oakland, California. and BBC Studios is headquartered in beautiful, White City, West London. If you want to get in touch or have an object for us to consider, email us at 100 Objects at 99PI.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
总部位于加利福尼亚州奥克兰市美丽的住宅区。BBC Studios总部位于伦敦西部美丽的白城。如果您想与我们联系或有物件希望我们考虑，请发送电子邮件至100 Objects at 99PI.org。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。